foreign
is with us in Fort Lauderdale hey Greg
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave thanks for having me I sold my
place in California ended up with six
hundred thousand dollars in cash
and there's this beautiful Penthouse
condo in Pompano Beach I'm looking at
and I want you to tell me if it's the
dumbest thing in the world to buy it I
love Pompano Beach can I just tell you
that's my old hood
so I'm just throwing that out there
beautiful place yeah yeah it is well the
thing is it's uh 1250 a thousand 250 for
the maintenance fee is the Killer and
then I'd have to maybe get a little bit
of a mortgage above the 600 000 I got
for cash from my California place they
bought it for 750 in other words I have
that maintenance fee and who knows there
might be some ridiculous assessment for
say forty thousand dollars or something
you know so I'd be dealing with that but
I am single with no children
and uh I wonder if it's a fun great move
I mean it's a wonderful place or if it's
just stupid
what's your household income
uh I I'd say now I'm making about uh
between 50 75 000 a year 60 years old
okay
um
so here's I mean I I want you in five
years to pay off whatever mortgage it is
or three years can you do that right
yeah you don't be sick you don't be 65.
you can't do that yeah you don't want to
be 65 with a mortgage and a twelve
thousand dollar earn a 1200 maintenance
fee
right as long as you're able to get it
to where that that mortgage with all the
fees included all the taxes all the fees
included is no more than 25 percent of
your monthly take home are you able to
do it oh yeah
it really needs to be more than that
because you got to pay you got to just
say you're gonna take out like a hundred
fifty thousand dollar mortgage
and you got you got you know like you
need to be putting 40 or 50 000 on this
thing ever ever in licks I mean you need
to be hitting it hard
because because I want you
I don't want the condo with a dadgum
loan on it when you go into retirement
right
right if you got five years to clear
this so thirty thousand a year for five
years is 150.
okay can I got a couple million bucks
I've saved up too I've got investment
well there's a detail you left out come
on come on well you didn't ask I like to
I wanted to ask I wanted to answer the
question you like living life on the
edge I'm getting played here go get the
car dude go get the condo and write a
check for it don't take out a mortgage
just pay cash man just pay cash for it
and take out a mortgage oh my gosh